-We are in the Doombox.
Our next three songs will decide
tonight's champions.
It's time for
"Slay It Don't Spray It".
-♪ Better know the words
or you'll get sprayed ♪
-And here's how this works.
Players from each team will take
turns singing well-known songs
karaoke-style.
They'll have the lyrics
in front of them,
but when the music drops out,
they'll have to finish the line
from memory.
If they don't get the lyrics
exactly right,
the microphones in front of them
will spray water in their face.
But if they can slay it and sing
all of the words perfectly,
then their opponents
get drenched instead.
Each song is worth
50,000 points.
All right.
-All right.
-Nicole and Jason,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
-That's a good one.
-"Rolling in the Deep," Adele.
-Uh-oh.
-You have to decide
who's gonna sing.
-I like this song.
I think -- I like this song.
-Yeah, you like this?
I'll take that as,
"I'm singing the song."
-You got us, you got us.
-Really?
-How much water is coming out?
-Are you guys nervous?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I know.
Me, too, a little bit.
Yeah, all right.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Don't cry.
-Yes!
It's gonna happen, right?
-♪ And you played it, what,
to the beat, yeah ♪
What?!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Both scream ]
I'm sorry! Guys --
-It's more water than I thought.
-[ Laughs ]
-Jason knew he was gonna be dry.
-I knew I was good.
-Jason's, like, dancing
in there.
He's like, "I know
I'm gonna be dry."
-Yeah.
-Oh, you knew it was coming out
here.
[ Both scream ]
-So much spray.
-But it's so cold!
-Ooh, sorry about that.
-Oh, my gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared now.
-All right. Julia and Kelsea,
it is your turn.
-Here we go.
-Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
"Man! I Feel Like a Woman!"
Shania Twain.
-Whoo! Let's go!
-I feel like it's
a Kelsea Ballerini song.
-I would be nervous.
I would be nervous.
-Pressure's on.
-I don't want you to walk away
from the mics.
-I'm gonna be right here.
-Right like this, Jimmy.
-Whenever you're ready,
everybody.
-Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here we go.
-I'm gonna go for it.
I know we're gonna get sprayed,
Jason.
-I know what's about to happen.
-Oh, man.
-♪ To feel the way I feel ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I did it!
-I-I --
-You knew it.
-I knew it was coming.
-You knew it, you felt it.
-I committed.
-We knew it.
-Look at my face.
-So proud of you guys.
-Jimmy, my face is gone.
-You did a good job.
-I'm so sorry.
-That's 50,000 points
for your team.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We decided to just commit.
-It is time for the final round.
And this time, we're really
gonna raise the stakes
in this one.
Watch your heads
because we're bringing in
the big microphones.
Come on in, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Season two upgrades coming in.
-Jimmy, I'm soaking wet
right now.
-Hope you brought a towel.
[ Laughs ]
-Jimmy, is this more water?
-The four of you
are going to take turns singing.
And this round is worth
200,000 points.
So whoever wins this...
-200,000.
-...wins the whole thing.
Let's see what
our final song is.
[ Beeping ]
-I'm so wet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"I Kissed A Girl,"
Katy Perry.
-All right.
-Okay.
-Nicole, you're going
to start us off.
-I'm soaking wet.
♪♪
-Kelsea, you're up next.
Jason, you're up.
Kelsea.
Jason!
-♪ It felt so right,
it felt so right ♪
-♪ In love ♪
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Crowd ] Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-They got it.
-It felt so right,
but it was so wrong.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ In love ♪
-We have a winner!
Julia, Kelsea are tonight's
"That's My Jam" champions!
Get out here!
-Whoo!
-There's your Boombox.
-Yeah!
-There's your golden Boombox.
You are the champs.
Nicole, come on.
I'm -- Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
-Do we get points
for being soaking wet?
-Halle, Simu,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
"Poker Face," Lady Gaga.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now you have to decide
who's gonna sing this one.
Do you know it?
Who knows "Poker Face"?
-I think you should sing it.
-I will do it, Jimmy.
-You're gonna go?
All right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. Whenever you're ready,
please begin.
♪♪
Are you getting nervous?
-Yeah.
-♪ Show him what I got ♪
-[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
I'm so sorry.
-I didn't even know the words
to the lyrics.
-I'm so sorry.
You are so relieved right now,
Chloe. Oh, my God.
That is 50,000 points
for Adam and Chloe right there.
-Oh, my God.
We are so far down.
-Let's see that
in slow motion, please.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Chloe and Adam,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song you get.
-Mnh-mnh.
[ Beeping ]
-"No Scrubs".
-Okay, okay, I got it. I got it.
I got it. I got it. Okay.
-All right, here we go.
Whenever you're ready.
-Give it to me.
♪♪
-♪ Trying to holla at me ♪
-Yes!
-[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Sorry, sis.
-Can we --
Do you want a towel?
I mean, Halle. I'm sorry.
Who knew The Little Mermaid
was gonna get so wet tonight?
I had no idea.
[ Laughter ]
That is 50,000 points
for your team.
Can we see that once again?
One more time.
That's a good one right there.
Look at this.
-[ Slow-motion scream ]
-Wow. You knew it was coming.
Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Guys, it's time
for the final round.
And this time, we're really
opening up the floodgates.
Watch your heads because we got
the big mics coming in.
-The bigger, the better.
It's time to get wetter.
-Oh, no.
Okay. We have to get this.
-All right, now, all four of you
are going to take turns singing,
so pay attention
to your screens, okay?
You'll switch off line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail the lyrics
or you and your partner
will get drenched.
And this round
is worth 200,000 points.
So whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Let's see what
our final song is.
[ Beeping ]
"I Wanna Dance with Somebody"
by Whitney Houston.
Halle, you're gonna be
starting us off.
Whenever we're ready,
here we go.
-We got this. We got this.
Come on.
♪♪
Chloe.
Simu, you're up next.
Adam, you're next.
Halle!
Chloe!
Simu!
-♪ With somebody who loves me ♪
-[ Screams ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm sorry. We have a winner!
Halle and Simu!
You are tonight's
"That's My Jam" champions!
Get out here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You get your own Boombox.
-I get my own!
-Yeah. Come on out here.
You're the winners.
Come on out, guys.
Come on out.
Are you mad at your sister?
Come on.
Thank you all for playing!
Jabari, Quavo,
your team is up first.
-Let's go, then.
-Let's see what song you get.
-Let's do it.
[ Beeping ]
-"Rapper's Delight,"
Sugarhill Gang!
-I got this one.
-All right, good.
-Yeah, I got this one, man.
-Wait, you're gonna do
the whole song?
-Yeah.
-To this one.
-"Rapper's Delight"?
-Yeah.
-You're --
-I'll do the next one.
-You're Quavo, though!
-But I'll do the next one.
-All right, bud.
You're making the call
on this one.
-Watch this.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Okay.
Whenever you're ready, Jabari.
Good luck.
-I'm ready.
♪♪
-Uh-oh.
Hey.
♪ ...try to move your feet ♪
-Whoop, whoop!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Spraaayed!
-Got 'em.
-Get 'em, get 'em!
-I'm sorry, dude!
-They sprayed!
-[ Laughs ]
-Disrespect, I'm sorry.
You're a champ.
You nailed it!
-What can I say? I'm a --
-You crushed it.
-I'm an old soul.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's 50,000 points
for your team.
Let's see that in slow motion.
-Ohhh!
[ Laughter ]
Ohhh!
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ Laughs ]
-You're that cool?
How cool are you,
French Montana?
You don't even react to --
-Nah, I moved to the right.
-Oh, I understand. I understand.
Yeah, yeah, gotcha, gotcha.
French and Chance,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
-Oh, no.
-We got this.
-I don't know this one.
-"American Woman"
by Lenny Kravitz!
-Y'all don't know that.
-Nope.
-That's eclectic.
-Who's gonna sing this one?
-Chance.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah, okay, okay.
All right.
French, don't move out
of the way of the water.
You know what I mean?
-[ Chuckles ]
-You're sticking to the wall
a little bit there.
All right. All right.
[ Laughs ]
Chance,
you're laughing already.
You don't look confident to me,
that's all I'm gonna say.
-Let's just get it over with.
-Re-- [ Laughs ] Whenever
you're ready, let's hear it.
♪♪
Chance is good!
-Nope.
-♪ And I gotta sing this song ♪
All right, spray me. Go ahead.
-Nooo!
[ Laughter ]
-Can't come out.
And you had no clue.
You had no clue.
Okay, it just --
-I don't know
none of these songs!
He gave 'em "Rapper's Delight"!
-[ Chuckles ] All right.
It's "than spend my time
growing old with you"
was the lyric right there.
That's 50,000 points
for Jabari and Quavo.
Let's see that again
in slow motion right there.
[ Laughter ]
French, he did it again!
He moved out of the way again!
Oh, my God, it's so funny.
All right, look.
It's time for the final round,
and we're really gonna raise
the stakes on this one.
Watch your heads because we've
got the big mics coming in.
-Hope you brought a poncho,
honcho! [ Laughs evilly ]
-Oh.
-French, you see that?
-Whoo.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
All four of you are going
to take turns singing,
so pay attention to your screen.
You'll switch off line by line
when the music stops.
You have to nail the lyrics
or you and your partner
will get drenched.
-Uh-oh.
-This round itself
is worth 200,000 points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing!
-Oh, man.
-Look at how dry and happy
you guys are!
-Dry!
-[ Chuckles ]
-Let's see
what our final song is.
[ Beeping ]
"All Star" by Smash Mouth!
-We got this.
-All right. Quavo, you are
going to start us off.
♪♪
-♪ I ain't
the smartest tool in the shed ♪
-French, you're up next!
-♪ With her fingers
or her thumb ♪
♪ In the shape of an L's
her forehead ♪
[ Chuckles ]
-♪ Things had rules
and the ground hit running ♪
-[ Singing indistinctly ]
♪ So much to -- ♪
Oh.
-♪ You never know
if you don't -- ♪
-Chance, you're up!
-♪ Get the show on, get paid ♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Bell dings ]
-That's not right!
That's not right!
-Spray them! Spray them now!
-That's not right!
-Spray them now!
Spray them now!
[ Overlapping shouting ]
Jimmy, spray them now!
-No! No, run it back!
Run it back!
-♪ Get the show on, get paid ♪
[ Bell dings ]
Ohhh!
-Chance, this time,
you were correct!
[ Bell dings ]
They said it was right!
Let's give 'em one more spray
and let 'em know what's up!
-What?
-Yeahhh! Yeah!
-Yeahhh!
-Oh, y'all kidding, right?
-Oh, they cheated?!
-[ Yelling in slow-motion ]
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
-We have a winner!
French and Chance are today's
"That's My Jam" champs!
Come on out!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right here. French!
All right, Keke and Saweetie,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
"Wrecking Ball" by Miley Cyrus.
Now you have to decide
who knows "Wrecking Ball" more.
-No, none of us know this,
though.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay. I know so--
I know enough.
-I know the chorus.
-So you want --
Paper, Scissors, Rock?
Rock, Paper, Scissors?
-The voice should do it.
You are the voice.
-Oh, God.
-That's right.
-Pressure's on, Keke.
Here we go.
Get ready.
-I ain't gonna win this.
Okay.
♪♪
-Feeling confident?
Still good. Yeah!
-♪ All you ever did
was wreck me ♪
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aw.
-[ Laughs ] I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, bud.
Yeah!
Not only did you crush it,
but "wre-e-ked me" --
you nailed it!
Oh, wow.
You nailed it, nailed it,
nailed it.
Whoo! That is
50,000 points for your team.
Let's see what happened
to you guys in slow motion.
Oh, that's not fair. Oh.
-Aw.
-Okay, Will.i.am, Joel,
it is your turn.
Let's see
what song you guys get.
[ Beeping ]
Willie Nelson,
"On The Road Again."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which one of you guys
knows this song well?
-I got water all in my face,
so...
-So you're gonna give it
to Joel?
-I'm gonna go with Keke.
Go ahead.
-No, no, no. No, that's not --
that's not the way this works.
-She's great.
-That's not the way --
-Did you see earlier?
-That's not the way this works.
It's not the way this works.
Joel, I think we're just gonna
say you're gonna do this.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is great.
-Joel McHale singing
"On The Road Again"
by Willie Nelson.
-I'm taking these off.
-Here we go, bud.
-I love Joel.
♪♪
-Pretty good.
Will, are you ready to get wet?
Why are you [laughs]
-Don't want to get wet.
-♪ And then a bunch of other
stuff happens in this song ♪
♪ But these aren't the lyrics ♪
[ Laughter ]
-You got to stay in!
Get back in the -- Come on!
-Damn, they really
getting soaked.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't know.
-Your guess to the line was,
"a bunch of other things
happen in this song."
-♪ And a bunch of other things
happen in this song he wrote ♪
[ Laughter ]
So did I get it?
-No.
Look at you guys.
Supermodels, supermodels.
The correct lyric was,
"insisting that the world
keep turning our way."
That's 50,000 points
for Keke and Saweetie.
Let's see that in slow motion.
Watch Will go --
Yeah, there you go. Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, that's rough.
All right, everybody,
it is time for the final round.
And we're really gonna
raise the stakes on this one.
Watch your heads because we got
the big mics
coming in right now.
Look at this.
-The game's about to get better
'cause you're about
to get wetter.
-All right, now, all four of you
are going to take turns singing,
so pay attention to your screen.
You're gonna switch off
line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail the lyrics
or you and your partner
will get drenched.
And this round
is worth 200,000 points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Let's see what our final song
is tonight.
[ Beeping ]
"Celebration," Kool & The Gang.
You know that one.
Everyone knows that one.
-Yeah.
-♪ Celebrate good times ♪
♪ Come on ♪
-Yeah, that's it.
-Yeah.
-I'm not getting in there,
though. Okay, here we go.
Will, you're gonna start us off.
Will.i.am, here we go.
♪♪
-Whoo-hoo! Oh, shucks.
-That's all right.
Joel, you're up.
Yeah!
Keke!
Will.
-Come on now.
-Saweetie.
Joel!
-♪ We're gonna have a good time
to come together ♪
-Keke.
-It's not the lyrics, I know.
Please don't get my hair.
I'm not playin' with y'all.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my, God! Saweetie!
You fell apart!
[ Laughter ]
-Did we just win?
-You guys just won
"That's My Jam."
-Hell nah.
-Wow.
-That's for you, bud.
-Oh, my.
-[ Laughs ]
-You won.
That's the way the game works.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, bro.
-Oh.
-Oh, my God.
-Jimmy, this is so much heavier.
-No, no.
-Oh, my God.
-It's so much heavier
than I expected.
-The whole system is rigged.
-We got to talk.
We'll talk during the credits.